I can't stop it
was all smiles and confidence today
after Labor stepped up its game at the
local elections sakistama unveiling new
plans for the NHS alongside some more
familiar warnings about its future I
don't think the NHS survives five more
years of Tory government
and people say oh well we've heard this
before the labor party is always saying
it's time to save the NHS
but I say
look squarely in the eyes of the people
who work in the NHS who serve the NHS
and ask them Center Stage ambitious new
targets and a new focus on prevention
early diagnosis and Technology what was
missing though how much it will all cost
how do you expect the public to trust
you with the public finances if you're
not prepared to say quite
straightforwardly these are our plans
this is how much they will cost and this
is how we will pay for them this
challenge you put to me that we've not
said where the money is coming from is
just wrong actually are we going to have
the biggest increase in training for the
NHS that it's ever had in its history
yes are we going to pay for that by
abolishing the non-dom tax status yes so
what we've been careful to do is to say
where we're making changes what the
change will be and how we will pay for
it Labor's list of all the things that
they would do to improve the NHS is a
very long one there is no shortage of
ideas but about patience do they believe
that the party can deliver on all of
these promises Kia stormers track record
of making pledges and then reneging on
them is something he needs to address I
think I don't think it's in good hands
under anybody because I honestly don't
think they know what's going on at the
sharp end some people saying you need
more money but the point is do we have
enough people who actually want to work
in the health system you know that's the
thing some reservations as well from a
leading Health Think Tank well
commitments around
um heart disease and cancer are
reflecting a realistic 10-year plan to
improve but kids also committed to
restoring NHS waiting time standards
within five years those standards
haven't been met since 2015. and this
isn't just a backlog caused by the
pandemic this is a long-term challenge
around the performance of the NHS and I
do think five years whilst it's right to
be ambitious it's probably not
deliverable thank you today was Labor
trying to convince voters it is ready
for government part of a journey they
hope will end at Downing Street this
mates Sky News Essex